estávamos no início dos anos 90 quando o
meu irmao tentavam desqualificar este
enigma da matemática
um dia conseguirmos a nossa maneira de
montar um soco em peças encaixadas nos 7
séries
foi a nossa forma com 9 11 anos de dar
três governos um enigma para nós não
tinha qualquer outra função
acho que tanto o verso como heróica pois
afinal de contas resolvemos o problema e
ninguém nos tinha dito quais eram as
regras sempre mistérios
os primeiros livros que eram 15
histórias de sherlock holmes com do ator
além do réu ou várias outras obras do
água viva não de cinemas pra essas
histórias não transportavam não
descansava enquanto não sou essa função
enquanto não descortina cinema estaria
cansado por ter convosco faz um ator
todos vão reconhecer o final diz o
seguinte é mais bela coisa que podemos
vivenciar é um mistério
ela é fonte de qualquer arte vai em
qualquer ciência conhece não pára para
pensar e não se a china está como morto
perto crise da intriga e mistério
enigmas faz parte do ser humano tentar
descortinar qualquer mínima e talvez uma
das questões básicas estão fazendo os
interroga sobre o que não conhece
eu até acredito que quando fazemos
desenvolver as capacidades da observação
fascínio e até a criatividade por preço
temos que formular hipóteses
diria até que o enigma é capacitar e o
instinto resolver um enigma é talvez o
maior motor da evolução humana seria
porque há já uma experiência imagem é
convosco para perceber que algumas
reações pois já vamos começar com um
baralho de cartas que eu penso com
aquela quebra vamos conseguir acompanhar
bem essa distância importante abrir um
leque com as cartas
vou tirar uma carta qualquer caso
deixaram retorna assim no meio do brasil
e vou tentar fazer com que eu vi as para
cima
calma calma eu compreendo compreenda
comprei uns de frutal onde usar um pouco
suas casas outros ficaram imediatamente
a tentar desqualificar o imã ea tentar
perceber como é que eu faço
neste caso o movimento por questões que
vamos abordar era de certa forma
eventualmente simples bom uma vez em
relação à tecnologia é muito mais
interessante é que o que vocês vêm do
que o que eu faço em nome da função por
mais difícil que seja a chegar até ela é
uma trivialidade e sempre talvez no
busão de ix comentários no ano que vem
aquelas coisas que não compreendia que
pareciam contra por tudo o que eu
aprendi na escola conseguiu segurar
todos os livros e vídeos que encontrava
sobre o tema e muitas vezes saem até
chegar à feita porque aquela em câmera
lenta
a carta dizia consiste precisamente
nisso em criar em nós mesmos construímos
para criar um efeito mágico há duas
coisas que têm que obrigatoriamente
acontecer uma o efeito mágico em que
comprou por algo que a ciência indica
por exemplo quando maggi que facilitaram
objetos está no fundo a vencer a força
da gravidade é uma está contra por uma
lei da física por exemplo ciência e muda
no outro contexto por exemplo na lua ou
no espaço fazendo notar o objeto deixa
de ser
por que o filho já consegue explicar
outra coisa fundamental é que é
necessário provar que esse fenômeno não
acontece de uma forma explicável que foi
o que não aconteceu a pouco vocês há
pouco que eram muito poucos momentos
para acreditar no que estava a fazer é
mostrar um velho copas pois no meio nada
vos indicavam que este horário não tinha
mas copas conquistar todas as cartas
eram as copas
bom eu estava a dizer no fundo para
criar a ilusão para criar mais e ele
sabe cumprir alguns requisitos que
impeçam vossa mente chegar imediatamente
a função e para isso eu gostaria eo que
mais alguns momentos nomeadamente uma
testemunha e para isso trouxe aqui um
pasto rocha ressaltou que os açores a
idéia muito simples tanto o tiro de
pedra para a platéia
é claro que a pessoa vai participar não
é preciso comprovar com pedra ser a
pessoa que tiver à direita da pessoa que
tiver a sangrar o 23
edson já calma eu sou mágico não só para
alguém que pode pender a favor e vai até
o próximo sábado vamos prendê lo
a não buscar aí o juju também pode ser
pronto mas mostrava para ela ligar para
o pessoal me chama se i exército
adiantou espetacular esta coisa é das
coisas mais enigmáticas por hora
bom a sofia enquanto este horário como
eu têm cartas todas iguais
eu vou pra já deixaram o local assim
como precisamos ter porque não vou usar
um brasileiro será especial
portanto com cargas todos iguais não sei
que o edson não importa na hora do
almoço exatos e vamos usar tantos um
baralho como espectador a pensar em
termos combinados como essa você sabe o
que dizer
temos aqui um baralho de cartas com
agora sim que pode confirmar isso também
com todos estamos aqui porque assim a
câmera consegue apanhar candomblé cartas
completos com todos os cartões todos nós
um pouco mais na frente a gente vê que
poderia escolher a carta uma carta a
mesma forma seja completamente não não
retorne na verdade é que eu possa tomar
uma decisão ou seja não seja
influenciado em uma forma utilizando
tanto faz chorar nas quartas voltou ao
microfone e vai começar por cartas na
mão uma por uma não os faz virados para
cima mas por uma por uma quim mas quando
e quanto quiser quando você acha que é
certo que as páginas 14 paulo está aqui
em cima o dois poços ainda dói muito não
pode ser o quarto até o hotel a dez
crianças escreveu a escritora você
lembrar e e pode fazer agora é assinar o
2 deus dois dos alunos da escola
escolher mas afinal porque se vai servir
de prova e cruzou a 12 paulo no brasil e
não só favela que os criticam livramento
tac sofia consegue ver uma câmera quando
assim é fundamental que se dispunha
escolher aleatoriamente os filhos
completou ontem com a equipa
e então vamos usar os dois paus assinado
pelos fia para tentar realizar a
experiência ea pouco mas desta vez com
mais ou menos que estão a comprovar que
o que estou a fazer tantas horas
deixaram cartas impedida sensivelmente
no brasil chamada lá dentro e vou tentar
fazer com que tocar teve as próximas
filho eu não sou assim tão bom é só
deixar isso claro desde o princípio é
esse porque foste tu que se nesta quarta
feira por isso tem que ser duas tomadas
de forma que nem esse senhor não fala
quando sopra no curso do processo
agora sim viajou exatamente pra cima do
espaço destinado à escolha
claro que sim porque algumas variáveis
vão fazer outra vez agora em câmera
lenta e não queria sair da casa vai
colocar fim no meio do braille vai
fechar lá dentro senão no mês pode
sobrar chamado de deus quiser
melhor ainda melhor ainda seria fazer
isto uma carta marcada mas também na sua
estrutura física ou seja senhor que a
carta assim quero que fique com esta
gera dobra e vir na forma de informação
abi ackel instantes filha que a carta
viajar para o fim e 2
a mãe sofia agora eu vou poder a carta
várias formas no meio rural e vou ganhar
várias formas por exemplo não vai afetar
a américa do norte que você conhece
américa do sul é completamente diferente
da portuguesa não seja para mais ou
menos assim parece toda a gente tem para
quem saber ok
por mais que seguramente mais misturas
cartas a carta da filha está assinada
está marcada uma carta única no mundo
sinto que eu vou tentar encontrar com os
meus sentidos com qual dos cinco
sentidos seria mais estranha encontrar a
carta mais esquisito o site que será a
quinta final em casa mas foi ainda mais
estranho mas os organizadores exatamente
o pão da trip fúria assinatura do recife
foi encontrado nesta quarta vou tentar
então não é ingênuo mas é muito giro o
santos aí vai um quilo uma carta
perfeitamente dobrado em 4 filha e disse
que qualquer carta
só assim a princípio uma carta escrita
livremente uma 12 palcos assinaturas que
construí minha e é exatamente
ia no princípio do princípio eleito
brasil tinha cartas todas iguais e pode
ajudar nesse horário é que ontem saí com
este horário e sai cartas todas iguais
excepto uma colher de 123 livremente
está aqui mesmo na vaga de boca seca
ajuda não seria incrível se houvesse uma
única carta de um baralho de 29 anos
todo eu comece uma única carga tivesse
virado ao contrário do douro azul possui
província campo bom
convém é junção e junção de vários
elementos que tornam um enigma
impossível funcionar em alguns casos as
coisas com vocês mais aqui ou perto dela
é para mim ela escolhe carta que
comprovar que mesmo pessoas tais provas
nos ajudam acreditar naquilo que estou a
fazer magia ainda mais do que isso
acontece não só esses momentos mais
técnicos mas também existem - por
exemplo uma atenção atenção é
fundamental
se vocês não tiverem acompanhar o truque
do princípio ao fim quando se conhece
por exemplo quando publicar também do
brasil viaja pra cima
se houver alguma distração sobral que o
faça mudar a atenção naquele instante
para o vosso ser vai haver um momento um
espaço temporal
jean ou inconscientemente em que essa
ação pode ter acontecido então deixa de
ser magia vocês acham que seria com base
em duas coisas importantes que teve com
o próprio público e tem a ver também com
o artista que está em certa forma
consegui prender a atenção do público
porque às vezes quando falamos dia
aumenta as pessoas falam muito né
capacidade do desvio da atenção se na
nossa girino nossos termos
michael jackson era fazer errado a
direção da atenção mas mais importante
do que isso e saber direcionar a atenção
pronto armas e aparentemente contradiz
as leis da ciência
no entanto elas a esse precisamente
nessas leis para tornar possível não
havendo nada de sobrenatural significa
que por mais impossível para essa função
ela existe as pessoas perguntam como é
que se cria um truque novos como é que
basicamente é tudo muito simples
o segredo é apenas imaginários que
estamos num mundo em que tudo é possível
em que não há barreiras físicas
quaisquer barreiras físicas e pensarmos
se eu fosse imagem porque eu fui
acontecer depois e juntarmos o
conhecimento prévio conhecimento já
tínhamos antes e juntá-lo eventualmente
ideias novas que surgiam para aproximar
o mais possível o mundo à realidade do
mundo da ficção do mundo da fantasia ao
ficar tantos anos a desenvolver e
apresentar em línguas que aprendi com
isso uma missão que orienta todos os
outros aspectos da minha vida
acredito sempre tudo é possível
há sempre uma função disso porque tem
muito a hipótese três governos qualquer
mínima ser algo realmente importante
para vocês não desistam
mas a solução está mesmo ali à espera de
ser encontrada independentemente de
quais sejam os enigmas da nossa vida
pessoal ou profissional
tal como problemas ea premissa deve ser
sempre tudo é possível
mesmo nos focarmos nos sobretudo se
acreditarmos tudo tem uma função
leão